Good afternoon, everyone. I hope you're all enjoying this
spectacular AACR meeting and that you're not
burned out yet.
My name is Lori Freedman. I'm the Chief Scientific Officer at Auric
Pharmaceuticals, and I have the honor of serving as the chair of this year's
selection committee for the AACR Award for Outstanding Achievement in
Chemistry and Cancer Research.
The AACR established this award in 2007 to
recognize outstanding, novel, and significant chemistry
research, which has led to important contributions in basic or
translational cancer research, cancer prevention or
diagnosis, or the treatment of patients with cancer.
For the next award cycle that will be celebrated in 2027, we
are happy to announce that the Mark Foundation will be sponsoring this award.
This year's honoree is a scientist whose work has had a profound impact
on our understanding of cancer biology and the creation of widely
used chemical tools that are paving the way to new therapeutic
strategies.
The 2026 AACR Award for Outstanding Achievement in Chemistry and
Cancer Research is being presented to Dr. Cheryl H.
Arrowsmith, senior scientist at the Princess Margaret Cancer Centre and
professor at the University of Toronto.
Dr. Arrowsmith is being honored for her pioneering research at the
interface of chemistry, structural biology, and oncology.
She's widely recognized for transforming cancer drug discovery through the
development of potent, selective, and openly available
chemical probes that have become indispensable tools for the international
cancer research community.
Through her leadership of the Structural Genomics Consortium,
a landmark public-private partnership dedicated to open-access
research, Dr. Arrowsmith has led major efforts to
develop chemical probes for the discovery and validation of novel druggable
targets.
Her career-long commitment to bridging chemistry and cancer biology
has enabled researchers worldwide to uncover new mechanisms across
multiple cancer types.
Among her many contributions, Dr.
Arrowsmith and her team, in collaboration with the Ontario Institute for
Cancer Research, have developed numerous first-in-class chemical
probes targeting epigenetic regulators.
Probes that are openly available and enabling cancer researchers to unveil
novel mechanisms of oncogenesis and translate basic
discoveries into therapeutic strategies.
Additionally, her team's discovery and development of the novel inhibitor
OICR-9429 demonstrated activity against
mutant p53 and WDR5, leading to further
development in the biotech pharma arena for leukemia.
More recently, her work has identified vulnerabilities within the protein
arginine methyltransferase family, PRMT.
As part of the Stand Up to Cancer Brain Tumor Stem Cell Dream Team,
her study showed that PRMT5 inhibitors impair RNA
splicing and stemness in glioblastoma stem cells.
More recently, her work revealed PRMT1 as a critical vulnerability
in clear cell renal carcinoma via a PRMT1
inhibitor, interfering with RNA metabolism, leading to DNA
damage and impaired tumor cell survival.
Throughout her distinguished career, Dr.
Arrowsmith has continually adapted to the evolving
challenges of cancer research. She helped lay the foundation
for modern structural genomics through development of a pilot project for
large-scale systematic methods for protein structure determination.
Her seminal structural work on p53 and its paralogs
revealed critical insights into tumor suppressor regulation and protein
conformational dynamics that continues to shape our understanding of
cancer biology today.
Dr. Arrowsmith drives a highly productive research program, which
has attracted more than $300 million in research funding and generated more
than 415 peer-reviewed publications.
Her work has had a broad global impact with more than 49,000
citations, placing her among the top 1% of the world's most
highly cited cancer researchers.
A staunch advocate for open-access chemical biology and collaborative
science, she has transformed the landscape of cancer research by
broadening access to high-quality chemical tools,
empowering current and future researchers to probe
cancer biology with unprecedented precision.
Her many honors include election as a fellow of the American Association
for the Advancement of Science in 2015 and the Royal
Society of Canada in 2020.
Most recently, she received the 2024 Dr.
Chu Wei Memorial Prize in Cancer Research in recognition of her
exceptional contributions to understanding chromatin regulation and
advancing cancer drug discovery.
It is my great honor to introduce the 2026 recipient of the
AACR Award for Outstanding Achievement in Chemistry and Cancer
Research, Dr. Cheryl Arrowsmith.
Thank you very much, Dr. Freedman, and thank you to the committee
who has awarded me with this honor.
And I'm very humbled and pleased to
review some of our research today and to tell you about our
past and ongoing research to bring
chemical biology to the masses, if you will, through use
of chemical tools.
So these are my disclosures. The SGC is a public-private
partnership, so we receive a lot of funding from different
industry sponsors.I want to frame my work
first of all, in the context of precision medicine.
Precision medicine or personalized medicine, if you will, is all about
finding the right therapy for the
right patient. And in cancer,
every patient's cancer is very distinct.
And so what we'd ideally like is a
large pharmacopeia of medicines for the
clinician to choose from, and a detailed understanding
at the molecular level of a patient's cancer, and the
ability to link
one of those potential medicines to
a molecular vulnerability in the
patient. But we're very far from this right now.
And so what we and colleagues,
the way we're thinking about this, is if we had
much more pharmacological tools at our disposal in
the early research area and clinically relevant
patient-derived models such as tumor organoids,
patient cell lines, and explants, et cetera, we could
explore a lot more the
matching of which types of
chemical agents were effective in specific
types of
patient disease. This was proposed in an article
in 2019 that I'll get back to, in which we
propose eventually trying to have tools
for every human protein.
So all the work I'm going to tell you about is highly
collaborative.
Hundreds,
I don't know, maybe thousands of colleagues around the world
have worked with us over the years at the SGC and also with
me personally. So as Dr. Friedman pointed
out, the SGC is a pre-competitive public-private partnership.
We're working in the areas of early-stage drug discovery, where open science
is
able to propel the field forward. And as our
name suggests, we started off as a high-throughput structural biology
organization, and for the first almost 10 years or
so, we really pushed
hard on high-throughput structures of human proteins.
We contributed many to the
protein database that harbored those structures.
And I'll come back to later, many of our
structures were used, and the challenges
at the time for
people who were trying to predict protein structure,
and
for the longest time, protein structure prediction really didn't work
too well. And then finally, through this CASP project that we
contribute a lot of novel structures to, the AlphaFold team
was able to show that AI was
finally able to make a great
breakthrough in that area. And I'm going to come back to this at the end because
ideally, we'd like to see a breakthrough like that in the prediction of
drug-like small molecules that bind to proteins.
So
around
10, 15 years ago, we had
made a
lot of proteins. Also, the field of epigenetics was really
becoming
to the fore, especially in the area of cancer research.
And we started using a lot of the proteins that we were
solving structures of to also
try to understand small molecule binding and create
chemical tools that we call chemical probes to
these proteins.
And more recently, as I just alluded to, we're trying to
use a data-driven approach to drug discovery to generate
information that will support machine learning
methods to predict protein-small molecule interactions.
And I'll come back at the end of my talk to this
global effort that we're leading called Target
2035 to make a pharmacological modulator of most human
proteins by the year 2035.
So in the meantime, I'll tell you about
the work we have done a bit in the past with a lot of our
collaborators and where we're going in the future in
the end. And a lot of this has been focused in the area of
epigenetics, which is something I'm very interested in, chromatin regulation,
transcriptional regulation.
One thing I'll point out here is you'll see that as we started
doing more and more chemistry and creating
chemical tools, we started getting more and more
of our industry partners joining us.
And I think that shows the
real synergy between what we're doing in academia and
that is a value to the pharmaceutical
industry to
work in the open and in the beginning, in the early stages of drug
discovery.
So, what is a chemical probe for the purpose of this talk and
the types of research I'm talking about?
It is a drug-like small molecule, including now degraders or other
proximity-inducing agents, that selectively modulates the
biochemical activity of a specific protein or
small, very closely related proteins and cells.
So it should be potent, it should be selective.
If it's not selective, you can't relate its activity to a specific protein.
Active in cells at least, and even better if it's
good enough to do in vivo work, but need not be necessarily and
should not haveOff-target toxicity effects.
So we've been making these types of tools with industry partners and also
academic medicinal chemists for
15, 20 years or so, and as
I'm sure this audience knows, they're very complementary to genetic methods.
The ease of use in cellular systems is much more
diverse than
genetic methods, closer to the therapeutic modality.
We can study temporal
and reversible effects.
I think the most important thing is it
enables the development of
therapeutic hypotheses that can be tested.
And all our probes are available to the community
with no encumberment.
Most of them are commercially available, and we
don't get any
financial benefit from it. We just want to make them available
and
sow the seeds for better understanding human biology.
A quick
plug for the Chemical Probes Portal.
This is something supported by the SGC, but also
ICR in London and Paul Workman and Susanne Müller-Knapp
and Aled Edwards have been very instrumental in setting this up.
And so this is a resource for identifying good quality chemical
tools. You can get a review for
tools for over 600 targets now, and this will be
growing.
So especially any trainees in the audience, or
people who are just looking for
what's the best modulator for this protein I've run across or
this gene I've run across, have a look here.
So,
as I mentioned, over the last 15 years or so, the consortium as a whole
has identified around 200 chemical probes.
Half of these came from industry, from industry's internal
research programs and have been donated.
We call them the donated chemical probes.
And I worked
primarily in the area of epigenetic regulators, particularly
methylation signaling. My colleague, Stefan Knapp
from Oxford and then later Frankfurt,
led the bromodomain efforts, and together
we've created about
50 or
70 or so
modulators of epigenetic regulators.
So why did we choose epigenetics? And that's because
epigenetic mechanisms are responsible for many of the hallmarks of
cancer, as outlined here. I won't go through all of them, but
the key factor is that these
cancer-specific epigenetic states create
liabilities or vulnerabilities, and they are reversible or
changeable by modulating their
epigenetic
orchestrators, if you will.
And if we get down to a more molecular level now,
it's really acetylation and methylation of lysines and,
in some cases, arginines and methylarginine
that we're studying mostly here.
As shown in the lower left, the pockets that
recognize methyl and acetyl lysines and arginines
are narrow, aromatic-rich or
aromatic-lined pockets, and very good for
recognizing these post-translational modifications.
But they're also the physical chemical properties that are compatible
with drug-like small molecule binding.
And so these are the modifications that are on the histone tails
of the nucleosomes, which are the central element of
chromatin, and
the various enzymes that
write, deposit the marks, or
erase the marks, or recognize the marks, together
orchestrate whether the chromatin is compacted and
not open to transcription,
or more open and more transcriptionally active.
So it's very complex and
several hundred proteins involved in
this.
So this is
almost
the collection of chemical probes, epigenetic probes that we've
developed. I've run out of space on the slide, so it's probably missing
a few. So on the left, in the greenish, are
acetylation regulatory targets, proteins,
with their relevant chemical probes, and on the right are
methylation-based regulators with their chemical
probes. And you'll note that whenever possible, we try to have
a structurally similar but inactive
compound as an inactive control or a negative control.
And these days, once there's a chemotype
out there that will bind to a protein of interest,
somebody's going to turn it into a degrader or a PROTAC.
And so many of these, even more that are annotated on here, have been
turned into targeted protein degraders.
So it's a very exciting time
in chemical biology from that respect as well.
And I'll touch on one of our degraders that we recently made
in a
little bit.
So one of the key things I've enjoyed most
about working with these tools
is collaborating with my colleagues at Princess Margaret and
neighboring institutesWho have patient-derived
disease models such as
brain tumor organoids, for example, colorectal
cancer organoids, patient-derived blasts
from poor prognosis AML,
clear cell renal carcinoma, and others.
And we can take this relatively small collection of compounds.
This is not high throughput screening.
This is a collection of very well-characterized chemical probes, and
test whether these models are susceptible to
growth suppression or cell killing in the
presence of a given probe. And when we see that growth suppression,
that tells us there's some vulnerability
linked to
inhibition of that
target of the chemical probe. And you can see that most of the
compounds
do not do much to most of the models, but in some cases they do.
It's not surprising that the BET inhibitors up here,
across here, are growth suppressive for almost
all cancer types. But we're more interested in cases
like this one or this one, where some of the models
respond to a given agent, but others don't.
So we've done a lot of work in instances like this to understand
what makes a given sample susceptible to
a given agent and what makes the other ones not
respond. And this reveals specific mechanisms of action and
specific biomarkers, in fact, of
cancer types that will respond. So we've done a lot of work in this area.
I show some papers here from our group, but
my other colleagues in the SGC have also collaborated a
lot
for
publishing other things, other papers.
So what are some of the learnings that we came across, particularly in the
aspect of epigenetics? So context matters.
For the same cell type or cancer type, different
epigenetic cellular states, even subtle ones, can
cause different cells to
respond differently to the same chemical probe.
And that's how we can discern responders from non-responders and what's the
molecular or biochemical mechanism behind that.
Full phenotypic effects often take days or weeks, particularly with
methylation signaling, and this is due to it takes a long
time for transcriptional reprogramming to occur.
And for methylation, the turnover of methyl groups on chromatin is
slow. You often have to wait for cell division, in fact.
Inhibition of arginine methylation, I think, was
underappreciated until a lot of use of these
arginine methyltransferase inhibitors to
reveal the dependency of RNA splicing, proper RNA
splicing, on arginine methylation.
Because inhibition of arginine methyltransferases really
messes up splicing quite a bit.
And that can be exploited in a number of cancers, as we've
published. Many epigenetic probes
promote the expression of repetitive elements, which can
cause
an innate immune response, sort of akin to
the viral response, the so-called viral mimicry.
And immune cells,
T cells,
et cetera,
are highly susceptible to modulation by epigenetic regulators,
because T cell differentiation and
polarization is basically an epigenetic process.
So these are revealing a lot of the opportunities that are
available with epigenetic modulation.
So our collection
has targeted most of the major arginine and
lysine methylation sites on
histone H3, as shown here. The blues are the lysines.
And also some
non-nuclear or non-histone proteins, including p53, for
example, gets methylated, and some others.
So
by using the
collection, we can really do a lot of modulation of the
epigenome.
One residue we were not able to make catalytic domain inhibitors to,
and I'll get back to this
one in a bit, to describe our work on
trying to target lysine 36 using the reader
domains
of this protein instead of the catalytic domain.
So, yeah, a quick overview of the protein methyltransferase
family. The lysine methyltransferase is shown here in the center
in a phylogenetic tree
representation. And then there's a smaller collection of
protein lysine methyltransferases, where DOT1L is an important,
sometimes oncogenic protein, and the arginine
methyltransferases. These all have a beta barrel structure.
That's why they're separate from the set domain methyltransferases.
But they all use S-adenosylmethionine as the
cofactor, the methyl source.
And so originally, it was thought that compounds that bind
in the cofactor site would be great starting points for
inhibitors. Turns out that most of
the SAM binding sites are
quite polar, and so compounds that bind in those sites tend to
be polar and therefore not very cell penetrant.
So more often, we were more successful in getting compounds
that banged in the substrate binding site.
And so these are the
aromatic line pockets that I described that
bind to the lysine and arginine and the methylated
versions of them. We've also identified a number of allosteric
inhibitors of the arginine methyltransferases, which are dimers.
And then at the dimer interface, you can get allosteric
binders.And then this subset of
methyltransferases, the polycomb
PRC2 and 1
enzymes, and the mixed lineage leukemia and
SET1
MLL proteins all require
quite complex multi-protein
complexes for their activity. And we've identified
inhibitors of the interactions amongst some of those
proteins, and I'll show you an example of that in a minute.
And then finally, as I mentioned, NSD2 and NSD3, we've been able
to target through their reader domain and by making degraders.
So just a quick
vignette of
typically how we go about making a chemical probe.
And early on, we worked on this protein
WDR5 because it's a central component
of the active region of mixed lineage
leukemia
methyltransferase. MLL1 in particular,
not as much in MLL 2, 3, and 4,
1 is very dependent on the WDR5 subunit interaction,
and this protein is rearranged and
dysregulated in a lot of human cancers.
So we're targeting WDR5 here. We're
targeting its interaction. Here it is from this structure, not
our structure, but a beautiful structure with WDR5 and MLL.
One of its tails, or peptide regions, binds in the middle of
this donut shape.
And that's shown here. So what we're trying to do is disrupt this
interaction. And we started with a screen, and
this was a collaboration with the OICR, Ontario
Institute for Cancer Research. And we identified this small
molecule that binds in the center of the donut where the peptide binds.
But it's weak, right? And so we need to do some more med
chem on this, guided by the 3D structure that we solved.
And
this was a beautiful collaboration in which we ended up with an
active
compound, OICR-9429, shown here,
which binds exactly in the substrate in the peptide-binding
pocket,
shown right here, an inactive control with an oxygen here
instead of nitrogen. And so we can see in a peptide displacement assay,
the inactive control has no binding, and
the active compound displaces the MLL peptide.
So then we need to show if it's active in cells and engages the
target. And so for this, we made a cell line
with a FLAG-tagged
WDR5 and could pull down, this is three
replicates,
we could pull down the MLL protein
without any compound competing off.
But then in a dose-response manner, you can see it competes off
MLL. And also you bring along
RBBP5, which is another component of the complex, and that can
be competed off too. This work was done by Dalia
Barsyte and her team.
So it's potent, it's selective, it's active in cells, and that's our
criteria for a chemical probe.
We then worked with collaborators in Vienna
and Shelly Berger's lab at Penn and showed that this
compound was very effective at
modulating and
preventing growth of
cancer cells that had aberrations in MLL signaling,
either a mutation that apparently recruited MLL in
this P30 mutant
leukemia, or in the case of
P53 gain-of-function in breast cancer,
where the MLL1 was apparently upregulated.
It also had growth suppressive effects here.
So this
really said to us, these pathways were not
on the radar of WDR5
inhibition until we did this work, and this was
the evidence to
inspire
Reem Alabar and her team at OICR to try to further develop
these molecules into a preclinical
asset. And they did that, and they eventually
partnered it with Celgene. And so
we
were very excited with
WDR5 work, shown here.
We also worked with AbbVie
just shortly after that to define a
chemical probe that disrupted the interaction of the EED
subunit of the polycomb repressive complex.
And Novartis independently also made
an inhibitor of that interaction
and took that to the clinic. And so these are the first
demonstrations of drugging WDR proteins.
We got very excited about this possibility.
This is one of the largest protein families out there.
The size of kinase in the kinome and maybe a little bit
larger. And it's full of E3 ligase
subunits, and it's also a family
that has the largest proportion of proteins that
have cancer dependencies in them as well.
So that inspired us to
take a diversion now from epigenetics and talk about
ourOur work on the WDR family. And
so we started a campaign in around
2000, right at the beginning of the pandemic, to
make a whole bunch of these WDR proteins.
They all have the same fold, shown here, this beta propeller
doughnut shape. But what's conserved is the fold,
the doughnut hole where peptides bind is not conserved.
And so when we get compounds that bind in here, they're exquisitely
selective, which is really nice. It's not like a protein family where
the
active site you're working towards is very similar.
But then it means we need to discover a new chemotype for every different protein.
So here's what we did. We
made a lot of these, and we solved some structures, but we took 16
WDRs and two epigenetic proteins as non-WDRs,
and we collaborated with xChem
and their spinout company called XVA AI,
which was bought by Relay, and collaborated with Google
to do
a number of screens of these WDRs using
DNA-encoded library screening, and then to use
machine learning to predict from
the
DEL data, which is billions of compounds, but they're all
each
tethered to DNA.
We use machine learning to predict which compounds that are
commercially available off the DNA might bind to the
protein of interest. And from that,
we analyze about 3,000 compounds for 18
proteins.
And each ML model is for a specific
protein. And
then we analyze them for binding through a number of
primarily SPR, and then on some other biophysical methods.
So here's the results. This was published last year.
For a number of proteins, about a third of the group, we
identified
low micromolar
drug-like compounds that were progressable in terms of medicinal chemistry,
and they were all new compounds and
chemotypes, and
quite a few we solved some structures for so we could see how they were binding,
and they all looked like good starting points.
And then some weaker ones. And if we analyze this
data in terms of drug ability or ligandability of the protein family,
each dot is a different WDR protein.
Ligandable scores using this DLL ID
measure are shown here. So many of them are in the
so-called druggable region, but a few are not, and some are
right on the border. Even DCAF, especially DCAF1, for example,
and LARC2, and these are two proteins where we're making some nice
progress with.
For any individual proteins, we didn't really need to
purchase or screen that many
purchasable compounds. And
when we did get compounds that bound, they were explicitly
selective, as I mentioned, because each of those pockets is different.
So more recently, we've been working in the area
of
modulators of the ubiquitin
system. This is with the advent of proximity methods and targeted protein
degradation. So I show a number of papers that we've worked on
here. And for the last few minutes, I want to just quickly touch on work we've
done for the NSD2 methyltransferase.
Now we're going back to epigenetics a little bit to try to
use targeted protein degradation in this case.
So NSD2 is implicated in a lot of cancers, and
particularly
the
multiple myeloma, and then there's an ALL type
mutation that is activating the protein, and so these would probably be
two that we want to look at. Either inhibitors of the
methyltransferase activity, which we were never able
to identify catalytic inhibitors, or
perhaps degraders. It makes this dimethyl mark on
lysine 36, which is a mark of active
transcriptional region of the chromatin.
So we worked with Lindsay James, a wonderful
medicinal chemist and great collaborator at University of North Carolina,
and we worked together to identify this chemical probe that
inhibits the interaction of the PWWP domain with
the dimethyl lysine on lysine 36 of histones
and in a peptide
context and also in the nucleosomal context.
And
it didn't really have much of a phenotype.
There were some hints of growth suppression.
But it really didn't knock the entire protein
off the chromatin. You can see it has all these other reader domains
that probably keep it anchored on chromatin, and it wasn't inhibiting
the catalytic set domain. So we thought,
well, why don't we try to turn this into a degrader?
And
long story short, we were able to, not by the original design that we
made, but fortuitously, we discovered
a series of compounds that
harbored a primary amine, so just a slight
extension of this binder to
NSD2 with a primary amine that
recruited FBXO22, part of the cullone
complex.So drilling down a little
bit, here's some chemistry for you, chemists.
The primary amine-containing compounds we discovered
were converted to aldehydes by amine oxidases in the
media or the serum. So this compound, which was our chemical probe, is
kind of like a prodrug.
And over time, in media that has
fetal bovine serum in it, or also Lindsay's group
showed that a human serum has this property to turn it into an
aldehyde, and you can
inhibit that
generation with amino guanidine,
for example, and that this is the active species.
And so we showed that,
for example,
through a number of methods, and we can generate this
molecule, which is just as potent, and
for in vitro biochemical assays, it'll
hydrolyze directly to the aldehyde.
And with Nick Brown at
UNC, he was able to solve the cryo-EM structure of
the cullin complex with FXO22
and NSD2 in the probe bound. And it's
hard to see here, but cysteine 326 is where we
identified the hemithioacetal
reaction with the formation with the aldehyde unit.
This is the probe shown here. And if you mutate that
cysteine, you don't get any degradation.
So this was exciting, and now we have an inhibitor that really
wipes out the dimethyl mark
in most cells. And we worked with Jonathan
Licht, who studies the multiple myeloma and the
mutant ALL cells. And he has this nice set of
isogenic cell lines that
either have in red or do not have the
activating mutation. And so you can see, again, with a
long delay time, because of the nature of
the epigenetic reprogramming that
needs to go on,
over a longer time,
especially 18, 21 days, we get a great
dose-dependent reduction in the mutant cells
only.
So these have the activating mutation.
They have a dependence on NSD2, and the wild-type
cells
are not dependent so much on it anymore.
And then perhaps more interestingly,
or as interestingly, Jonathan's group showed that
in the
mutant cell lines, that you could reestablish
their sensitivity to dexamethasone, which is the
standard of care for that disease,
and it's a childhood leukemia. So that was exciting
as well. So,
there's great excitement about targeted protein degradation and other proximity
methods. So now,
all you really need is a ligand to one protein of interest and a
ligand to
another protein of interest that could modulate it, whether it's an
E3 to degrade or maybe something else.
So,
it's exciting times. So let me summarize.
Chemical probes are among some of the most useful tools in biology
and drug discovery.
We have made a lot of these, and they've inspired a number of
clinical trials based on the biology that we've shown with them, we and
others have shown with them.
And now many groups, I'm happy to say that other
groups that make useful tools are starting to make them
available to the community,
and
share without too much hassle of MTAs, et
cetera.
Nevertheless, we still lack chemical tools for most human proteins,
and despite extensive links
to many diseases, and therefore, we need more tools and faster ways to
make them. And in the last two minutes or so, I'm going to go over
what we're doing in that direction.
So this just summarizes, again, these are the human genes ranked
for the number of
publications on that gene. And
you can see that a lot of the-- even 20 years after the genome
sequence, most of the activity is still on a small set of
proteins. So we would call this the dark proteome.
If you look at unbiased genomics, almost every protein can be
linked somehow to a disease. So this is a huge
therapeutic opportunity.
I think also with the advent of
proximity-inducing methods, it's also an
opportunity to think more creatively about how to
modulate proteins of interest and maybe not just directly inhibiting
enzymes.
So
again, pharmacological modulators are arguably one of the most useful tools
to sort out protein function, just basic biology
function, but also good starting points for therapeutics.
And that's why we think we need tools for all the human
proteins. And that's the objective of this initiative called Target
2035. So Target 2035, you can read more about it.
Here's three papers and the website that describes
the objective, the rationale that I
just explained, and how we're going about it.
And I'll just take two slides to explain how we're
thinking about this. So,
I'm a structural biologist. We lived through, as I mentioned in the beginning, the
era of high-throughput structural biology, and then
the revolution brought about by AlphaFold.
It's-Not depressing for a structural biologist to see that now
you can just predict a lot, not everything, but a lot to do with protein
structure. It's really exciting, and I think it's really exciting because what it
means for other types of
chemically based science. So we're going to take some rules
from what we learned from this.
First of all, community-wide initiatives for open data at scale.
So the structural genomics was one of those in the area of protein
structure. And so now we are thinking about ligand discovery
at scale.
We want to enable AI machine learning with
well-curated open datasets that
are AI-ready, ready for the machine learning.
So the PDB, the protein database, was what AlphaFold
used to develop their algorithms, and we've developed
a
resource called Aircheck, which is going to house
protein-small molecule interaction data.
And then community benchmarking exercises.
I mentioned in the beginning this
critical assessment of structure prediction
challenge that the
SGC contributed a lot of new structures to
for
measuring whether people could predict them or not.
And we are doing this with established similar mechanisms
for predicting-- for judging whether
groups can develop algorithms to predict protein-small
molecule interactions.
So,
quickly,
over the next five years, we've secured a large international grant,
and our goal is to purify
2,000 human proteins. We're going to use DNA-encoded library
screens, a new and anti-selective ASMS
screen that we developed in Toronto. You can read about them here.
These are in partnership with Inamine and HitGen, who are making the libraries that
are going to be open, that people can buy and
know the compounds that are in it. For academics, this is going
to be game-changing because both of these methods
are largely housed in industry right now,
not very
available to academics. And then we're going to,
in our team, mostly in Toronto, but also in a few of the other SGC
sites, use orthogonal biophysical methods to confirm
hits. It's all going to go into the Aircheck AI-ready
database. This is open. People can look at it and see it and then engage
with the
AI community and the challenge community to
both put the ML models into-- It's a
database for the data, but also a place for the
models to reside so people can compare models and
understand why some work better than others.
And then I'll end with a call to anybody who
has good targets you're passionate about,
whether it's just a
genetic screen and you think that would make a great target.
We're very interested in cancer targets, although the project is
non-disease
specific. But
send us your targets. If you have protein, you can even send us protein, and we'll
screen it, and the data will go
in the public domain. You'll get to see it, but everybody else will get to see it,
and it'll be a great starting point.
So
I'll end there. I'm
very privileged to work with
this wonderful group of people at the SGC. This is the SGC Toronto.
We have other sites in Frankfurt, UCL, University of
North Carolina, and McGill, and it's
just been such a pleasure over the years to work with everybody.
This is the leadership in Toronto,
my great team here, our funders
from
industry, and
we've worked with, again, hundreds from industry, and it's been,
again, such a pleasure, and I really want to acknowledge
these folks, especially chemists, put their time and
allow their compounds to be used by all.
And on the academic front, my lab in Toronto, my collaborators
at Princess Margaret, and particularly the projects I
talked about today, Lindsey Janes and her team, Rima
Alawar, David Euling, and the team at OACR,
and Stephen Fry, Nick Brown. Jian Jin has worked with us a
lot, and Umut,
also in his group, and Stefan Knapp in Frankfurt.
So thank you very much.
I think my time is up.